hi in this video we are going to be
talking about chips and something called
Moore's Law you've probably noticed over
the past 10 or so years that if you're
going to go buy an mp3 player you can
get a lot more storage for a lot less
price and you've probably even done the
thing where you're at the store and
you're like well I could get one now or
I could wait six months and the price is
going to be in half which might sound
ridiculous but this is actually a trend
that's been happening for a long time
let's talk about what makes a chip now
chip is just full of these little things
called transistors which are switches
that can either be a 1 or a 0 it's a
common theme for a lot about right so
all these little transistors fit onto a
chip and that's how it holds information
and store in ones and zeros what makes
these faster is the amount of
transistors the transistors mean 1 or 0
they're little switches that can hold
just a 1 or a 0 and their information
and the amount of transistors they can
fit doubles every two years since 1965
now it's most important about Moore's
law is that it's making technology more
accessible and more affordable to
everyone